Marshall yes I understand you have to
catch a red-eye
I know sir love well I agreed to a
screening of another film tomorrow in
New York months ago and I didn't think I
was gonna have anything going on in
February and uh and so I I it's at the
New York Historical Society it's a
fundraiser for them and so I have to yes
you you have to go so we'll we'll talk
to you first then so Marshalls film was
the neighbors window that twisty story
about the neighbors across from each
other it's really gotten a it's got a
lot of multiple audience Awards
including Best Drama at Halle shorts and
the audience award in Palm Springs it's
pretty that's pretty great so you are a
documentary filmmaker in fact an
oscar-winning documentary nominee
nominee okay no no always the bridesmaid
never the bride
[Laughter]
so what made you decide to take this
leap into the narrative work um I I
guess I got into documentary just
because I liked telling stories and and
after doing it for a while I've made a
bunch of feature-length films and some
shorts and I just wanted to stretch it
for a muscle and try something different
so so I remembered this a story that I'd
heard on a podcast years ago that really
touched me and and it seemed like a
perfect concept for a for a short film
and so I wrote it and got some friends
to help out and and we made it yeah it's
it's terrific and it really entertaining
and the performances are very authentic
um you you know your your lead actress
just did a tremendous job but she's
really shot the movie in to good job and
can you tell us something about that
true story that this was based on sure
so a woman named Diane wiper told this
story on a podcast love and radio that
was later rebroadcast on on radio lab
and she tells a story about being in a
similar situation having a couple of
young kids and and having a young couple
moving across the street that she
develops this sort of rear-window
obsession with and then the ending I
made up and the sort of twists of them
having the conversation on the street
and and you know all the the dialogue
and stuff but the sort of heart of the
story came from her and in fact she's
coming to the Oscars with us so we're
really excited she's been super
supportive of the film and very sweet I
love that ending it I love the you know
something we wouldn't have gotten from
Hitchcock's rear window which is the you
know yeah well we did get a point of
view from that but but not to this
degree yeah yeah great job thank you so
much and congratulations Thanks I'll let
you run if you need to run yeah thank
you so much thanks all you guys your
films are so terrific Miriam
yes yes Brotherhood which was that
really tough story of the family tension
in Tunisia really affecting story very
difficult I've now seen it twice and I'm
still really taken by it the tell me
about the the the actors that you worked
with is that a family or the brothers
they sure look like they are yeah no I
would have been very tough to find three
freckled redheads and tonisha that are
not related very very hard the casting
process I mean actually it was the flip
side usually you start with a script and
then you cast what happened with
Brotherhood is in 2016 I was doing a
road trip in Tunisia and I was just
wanting to you know connect with my
roots more and on the side of the road I
found the two older brothers with their
sheep
just walking and I was immediately
captivated with their faces as I'm sure
you guys feel and I wanted their photo I
just wanted their photo and they said no
so I drove away but it's still pretty
surreal to think that I went on this
mission but I wrote the script I was
kind of inspired by the reality of
Tunisia right now and a year and a half
later I went looking for them and I
didn't know their names I forgot where I
found them so it I just started driving
and going from village to village asking
if anyone knew redheads with sheep very
strange obsession I'm sure I'm gonna let
- a lot of strange encounters and people
are just you know either laughed at us
or thought we were crazy and we're
concerned but luckily you know we
recognized a pile of rocks where we
found them and we were led to their
house and what was crazy is in the
script I had written a role for a much
younger brother like an 8 year old
brother and when we arrived at the house
the first person who came out was Ryan
the little brother so it was kind of
crazy moment I was like okay I don't
need to find you you're here and so I
convinced the brothers to act in the
film and six months later we came back
we put together a little budget and we
came back and we shot the film yeah it's
a wonderful story big story of you know
of radicalization and but but done and
with such economy in such emotional
impact congratulations
[Applause]
Eve yes this is the an f2 football club
the really delightful film about two men
two boys and a donkey with headphones
exactly so this was inspired by some
real experiences in your life yeah which
of those three lanes there are so many
things but one when things inspired the
movie come from from my childhood and I
was the 13 or 14 I don't remember
exactly but I I was how often snuck out
in forbidden places with torchlight on
my friend at this time and one day we
found out the twisted spoon and a
camping stove and thousand of little bag
full of white powder and we thought that
this time it was probably drugs material
so we take all his loot on her
motorcycle and we dumped it in the river
so it's it's real but I kept his storage
secrets during 30 years so so the
characters are just really wonderful
they're really delightful can you talk a
little bit about how you evolved them
the relationships the the drug dealers I
love them I want to see a movie of those
guys you mean the the the the shield
when you talk about snowgo that you talk
about I always tie the smugglers yeah
you talk about this but I mean they're
all really fun Wow it's there they're
actors I knew what
at the end of the preparation because I
find them a very ten days before
shooting so it's yes Salim is a French
actor famous in France and in his
composition Misbah so we we work
together for find this game for display
so and they can they give me and I let
them play and because improv yeah it's
important to let the actor be creative
so yeah oh it was really fun and in fact
it won a series of audience awards
including best comedy at Aspen's short
fest that's a really fun festival that's
a great one congratulations
thank you yeah then Bryan Bryan Buckley
yes for Sariah
the devastating film
[Applause]
it's a yeah it's just very powerful and
um thank you you your background is very
unusual to come to this this film you've
you're you've done a lot of commercial
directing yes yeah you're you you're
known as the Superbowl King in fact for
the number of commercials you've done
for the Superbowl but this is just a
very powerful piece so so what brought
you to this this subject and and how was
it to deal with something that's just so
tragic yeah I mean I you know we were
very fortunate you know all of us
actually to be here and you know I've
been very fortunate in my career to you
know to have great opportunities and so
now and again I will look for something
that touches me that hits me and in this
case it was you know you get your
iPhone's going off all day especially
yesterday and you know you see the
little news thing that comes up on there
and then that day that particular day
and said it's at a locked door of fire
40:1
girls killed as police standby and that
was a March of this past year and marked
a two-year anniversary of their death
and I sat in my office and I just said
holy [ __ ] like I got you know clicked on
it and started going deeper and deeper
was a New York Times story and there was
an image of a little girl that was was
burned badly and was a survivor and I
started just going deeper and deeper and
all these parts started coming out you
know I mean one the surprising things
was like the romance you know the idea
was born on Valentine's Day that's you
know out of social between the boys and
the girls in a plot to escape and you
know I just said there god I am you're
reading how horrendous the conditions
were but there's love that exists
within this there are still kids trying
to be kids you know even as sex
trafficking was going through there and
it was it was just so complex and you
realized that you know we get into these
our world and you know I have been in
some tough places you know we've done
films in some tough places and um a life
goes on even in these very difficult
situations and these kids are fighting
so hard that I just felt like something
had to be made that they attempted to
get out of there I was actually a
woman's day March that was there you
know they left and and you know only to
be brought back it was just tragic to me
yeah and Matt can you talk a little bit
about what it was like to work with the
real life orphans of a well kids in an
orphanage to make this film yeah it was
a very unique experience we've uh we've
worked a lot of real people actors and
on actors in the past but to film with
refugees actually a couple times but the
orphans was uh was it was unique and the
fact that it's a difficult spec to go
cast for wouldn't Brian said he wanted
some to cast Guatemalan orphans so we
couldn't get the girls from Guatemala so
we went to Mexico City and it was just
it was an interesting process of instead
of coming with tapes and tapes of
options it was more like trying to get
inroads into some of these organizations
so you you had to come from a from a
place of knowing we weren't trying to
take advantage of any situation so it
was uh it was it was it was special
because once we did finally start to
meet some of these girls you realized
that they were they knew the story they
liked we didn't know the story and a lot
of people Mexico City no sorry but these
girls that were in these orphanages or
safe homes they knew the story there's a
network of of kids and these stories
somehow get passed along so they knew
and that was that was really interesting
to us so they were taking us seriously
they learned the script they tried
really hard and it was so they could you
know get this story out there and and
when Brian was working with him he you
know we had didn't we covered ourselves
and we also did some casting of actors
but he did not want to go that route
so we just kept workshopping and
workshopping workshopping and finally
the girls got I mean not finally Gabby
was there from the get-go but a
Stephanie it really had to head to
practice and she got there it was
determination she's so young but she got
there and it was a was a unique
experience as we were shooting like just
the girls that the sisterhood that they
built throughout the process and with
our acting coach and just it was it was
a real experience to watch you were
doing a real tragic story but watching
these girls come into their own and and
and be so strong was a really special
experience
yeah those performances were really
amazing the and the character that you
wrote sorry of her her wisdom her
childlike wisdom and sense of humor it
was really affecting thank you yeah
marvelous and Delphine with a sister I
don't know the 16 minutes that it was
like the tensest 16 minutes ever and
this is the second time I've seen it
sorry and I'm still yeah yeah you you
were an actress a long time and did that
affect how you approached this film as a
director because this was very unique or
we were on the face of the emergency
worker and very rarely on the collar
yeah but you you know how she felt
yeah because the the thing I wanted to
tell with that story was about like what
really bring me to that story was the
the idea of the connection between the
women and the sorority and hen Patti and
I I felt the right way to tell that was
to allow us to feel once feeling by the
other eyes if I can say so I had this
image in my head when I start writing
and start thinking about the film with
the back of the head of one of her and
the face of the other one so there was
something that was in my mind for all
the process and also I really may be the
actress part helped me to to think the
way we
to to do the process of a film and to
find the right way to tell a story and
to the experience we have to create for
actors also so we decide for example to
for both actresses they will not meet
before or during shooting so they will
they will have to imagine the other one
on the phone and you never know if it's
really helped but I believe in that I
believe it's it's it's bringing some
kind of sacred place to to shooting yeah
yeah no I think that that was part of
the authenticity of it you you really
felt at the end that she wanted that
connection
she wanted her name and I don't think
that's typical I remember hearing a
story like this on NPR recently about
how they evolved emergency workers to to
help people in a situation of extreme
danger what was the the inspiration for
this it was a true true story so I came
across a recording of a 9-1-1 call and
in the call you can hear a woman
pretends to call a sister but she's
actually calling the police so the the
ID was from a true events and at first
when I when I heard that I was
overwhelmed of course but I didn't think
I will do a film about that but the the
story really stuck with me stucked with
me and I I started to think okay I need
to find why these stories like staying
with me and yeah like I was saying
before it was really did the connection
and the it this story allows me to
approach violence communication and and
yet the worse and the better like you
can act so bad for a person but somebody
that you don't know can act so good for
you so that was something I wanted to
explore yeah very strong very powerful
thank you thank you
[Applause]
well congratulations on your nomination
wish you all good luck I'm sorry I I was
thrown by Marshall going first didn't
get a chance to ask you but I'm sure
you're gonna enjoy it
next this this Sunday so thank you again
thank you thank you
[Applause]